what else can you expect from a
trump-hating clinton-appointed judge who
went out of his way to make sure that
the result
of this trial was as negative as it
could possibly be now there's no
evidence that any of this is true every
lawyer I spoke to this morning said that
the judge handled the case perfectly
fine
speaking to
an anti anti-trump area which is
probably the worst place in the United
States for me to get a fair trial
will be appealing this decision it's a
disgrace I don't even know who this
woman is I have no idea who she is where
she came from this is another scam I'm
finding this a little difficult to
believe to be perfectly honest with you